there's a lot of
pacifist type of thinking in the in
world war ii as hitler was expanding
expanding hitler framed himself as a
victim
of the past of history he never attacked
anybody uh everyone's always threatening
to attack him that's kind of the
narrative and he keeps expanding he
keeps sweet talking with his charisma
all the countries around him
uh into sort of
embracing pacifism stay out of the war
until the war is on your doorstep
so france
just very sub-optimal
military strategy from the perspective
of the many european nations in response
to to hitler they were basically
hoodwinked by his his words so
then there's churchill winston churchill
who's who stepped up and says
perhaps irrationally from some kind of
economics perspective saying we're not
going to back down we're going to fight
germany and perhaps that step alone is
one of the biggest reasons that hitler
failed
in his expansion
that decision to fight back
how
what's the right way to do that if
you're a winston churchill
what's the right way to do that
if you're um
to uh to fight back
evil when violence is required now you
could argue that um
that no war is just but there is such a
thing as a just war index
and uh a lot of people argue if there is
a just war in the 20th century it's
world war ii
so how would you fund your britain the
war would would you require winston
churchill to convince the populace like
don't fight until they're fully
convinced that this is the right thing
to do you can't just make a decision for
them you have to convince them fully so
that they give their life and they give
their money to support the war is that
the right way to do it i think so and i
think when you have a true
um
threat and a true evil and a true force
that people really do think is genuine
you don't need to convince them i mean
when it's real people will want to fight
and people will want to pay to fight and
um
i mean i think
though on this particular example i
think you know that the best way to
fight hitler is to have not fought world
war one
and not take out the kaiser of germany
and if
if britain hadn't and written in the us
had not gotten involved in world war one
which really is
the senseless war about nothing what
what was in it and what was the goal
from anybody fighting that war if you
look at it
after world war one there were very
minor adjustments in the borders of the
countries that were participating so
germany lost some land austria lost some
land but really it wasn't all that
massive and it wasn't like you know
it wasn't like britain wanted to take
over germany and move their people into
germany and kick the germans out so
there was no real um value from that war
and that's why the british people didn't
want to take part in it and that's why
if they hadn't done this enormous the
criminal manipulation of
printing money to buy the pawns britain
wouldn't have gotten into the war
germany would still be a kingdom
and hitler wouldn't rise and yeah
there'd be a small changes in the
borders of various
european countries
i'd struggle to see how it could have
been worse i mean as i struggled to see
who benefited from four years of carnage
in
europe and then this was this came at
the height of civilization you know
before that
the people of europe had
um
they had the golden ear under the gold
standard they were trading with one
another they traveled and technology was
advancing and
they did not expect this war to last
this long
and you know my favorite story from
world war one is the christmas truce um
football game which i mentioned in my
book
british and german soldiers at the
height of the conflict they stopped on
christmas day and they played a football
game against each other
i mean this is not a real war where it's
it's it's a war for survival
britain didn't want to end germany
germany didn't want to end britain it
was just kings
who were emboldened by the fact that
they had a printing press
playing with the lives of the people and
um
take that away take away the printing
press take away their ability to print
money i think uh we'd have had a much
much much better 20th century
yeah the counterfactual history neil
ferguson is a historian who gets in
quite a bit of a trouble
basically uh well he's a brit
suggesting that if britain stayed out of
world war one there would be no hitler
there would be no world war ii yep i
agree entirely
you